The Joe Rogan experience,
I had my wisdom teeth pulled,
same kind of thing.
Excellent doctor,
right?
He prescribed me like 60 vicodins.
The next day I was eating burritos.
It was like,
wow,
this is.
I was expecting this worst pain in my life.
Everybody told me it was going to be the worst thing ever.
The wisdom teeth getting pulled was I was,
I was prepared for hell and I woke up the next day.
It was like,
this is great.
And I literally had those pills in my,
in my cabinet forever until I figured out,
and this was like 20 something years ago that a half a vicodin and a and a glass
of whiskey is so good time for awhile,
you know what I mean?
And so I came very close to becoming like kind of strung out there on pills
until I caught myself literally like,
wait a minute,
this is getting out of hand.
And I was able to just,
you know,
I was.
I luckily have that kind of personality.
I've never been really super addictive personality,
so I've been able to recognize a few times when I got close to like this could
get out of hand.
Yeah.
The luckily man,
I tell people that I smoked crack once.
What was that like?
It was,
it was bananas.
It was like the craziest,
greatest rush for like 35,
40 seconds and then it was gone and it was like I wanted more and a guy I used
to live with,
he was a crack so I won't even call it dealer a seller.
He just kind of sold it.
He wasn't even dealing because he wasn't even doing very well with crack and
that's,
you know,
I don't even understand,
but.
So like one night I was just kinda chipped off a piece and as I smoke some crack
man,
I was curious man.
But I recognized right away though.
I guess I know why people lose their lives behind this shit.
New Small crack.
Yeah.
What was that like?
I didn't like it.
I thought it was just,
it smelled weird and smell is off.
Putting taste is not good,
but like the rush,
I got it from it.
I was like,
Whoa,
for like a few and literally 30 seconds and then it was kind of like gone.
But you wanted it to happen again and I was just like,
Nih fucking go in there again,
man.
It was address rather.
I remember thinking I would rather do cocaine because they like took,
we took our cocaine made crack and I forget how to do it.
Like baking soda and
Freebase freebasing yeah,
that'd be crack is just like automatic,
like premade.
Freebase crack is I freebase we're so concerned with what kind of clothes we
were people who were like really into style.
They're always annoying,
annoying when they start talking to you about,
this is a,
this is Gucci,
this is and this is a,
this is a ralph lower end artist friend.
Somebody else.
There's all these older artists,
others get a little successful and they have like sleeves,
but they're like,
oh,
I only wear these types of shoes.
Being into clothes,
there's nothing wrong with enjoying.
I think are closer artwork though,
don't get me wrong,
but this people that are like really like obsessive Lee into style and like kind
of snobbish about it.
That's like a weird thing to give a fuck about.
You give a fuck that this guy has paint on his pants.
Like if you and I are hanging out and you have pain in your pants,
I could give zero fucks.
Is that like a better thing?
Whatever.
You know.
I'm just saying if you choose to wear a type of shoe,
were you choose to where I can make fun of time.
Portland,
you can wear anything you want to wear anything you want to everywhere.
But someone who's like into like rigid style.
Oh,
that's out of style.
That's my style.
Says fucking who fucking who.
You tell me what the hell board decides what's in style and not instyle wear.
Whatever the fuck you want.
If you want to wear some sweatpants,
where's some fucking sweatpants and anyone who cares is an idiot.
You fool.
You can that.
That guy's walking around in sweatpants and why don't you give a fuck?
Why would anybody care even slightly if someone's walking around wearing
sweatpants in the office,
in the board room,
what do you give a fuck?
What you have to wear?
That weird,
stupid outfit that you wear with these stiff corners,
these sharp edges and a tire around your neck,
enough and cuff links that are so fucking stupid.
You have to stick some metal,
extraneous pieces in there and tighten up better with the links because your
scholar folds over.
Get the fuck Outta here.
That's ridiculous.
We just Shiny,
stupid,
hard soled shoes.
What do you have wood in your shoes?
The bottom of your shoe is would really.
There's wooden your shoe.
What is it?
Fucking 18.
12.
Are you living in Denmark?
You have clogs on you fuckhead.
It's ridiculous.
Why would you have leather?
Shiny leather on the bottom of your toes?
They all slippery and stupid.
That is,
I guess scuffling at all.
What's with the tassels?
You fucking halfway tassels on the funnier shoes.
What is that extra fancy you fucking retard.
A leather tassel and silly and ancient.
Retarded and dum de dum,
de dum.
Who cares how you dress?
Remember how we started Joe,
you know,
it wasn't.
Everyone goes,
yeah,
there are no rules.
One man enter six men leave whatever we were saying,
but you know,
we couldn't figure out how to put the different fighting sports together.
So whose rules to use.
Right?
And so really the basis of the UFC was always,
you know,
no rules became this huge thing,
but it was also whose rules to use mean now you're going to get a boxer against
did you Jitsu Guy,
what are you going to use?
You can't,
there's no rules you can use.
Did anybody try to gouge eyes?
Was that it was illegal in the early one.
Well,
you know what I mean,
I always would hear about these wing Chun Masters.
They had 50 ways to pop your eye out with their thumb and I kept calling them
going,
bring your thumbs and do it man.
Don't talk about it.
Come and pop it.
But I am.
What would you have done if a guy lost an eye though?
Would you have done it?
Would we'd pick it up?
It was fun until it wasn't.
And you.
I mean,
you know,
the story we were,
we had backed off that marketing and where,
you know,
the unified rules,
were coming into place and you know,
it was
well for a lot of folks who don't know what we're talking about.
When the UFC first came out,
there were no way classes
and there were no rules and you could not,
you know,
the fighter could tap,
they could,
but no one could throw in the towel and the referee couldn't stop the flood.
That was on one at changed by two.
That was insane.
But anyway,
yeah,
that was insane.
So what is this sort of highlights it.
So that's the first episode,
the first UFC,
and then from there,
slowly but surely rule start becoming implemented strategies,
change rounds,
weight classes,
gloves.
Things got really interesting,
really fast and I'll think a lot of people were unaware of it.
If you think about the difference between 93 and 97,
I came in in [inaudible] 97 when Vito made his debut gloves.
We're still not mandatory.
They were optional.
Some fighters fought without gloves,
but it wasn't that the case was against gloves.
After I saw tank knockout,
what's his name?
Man to a
tank was smart.
He figured out he goes gloves or a weapon.
I'm bringing them.
Yeah.
You get getting your nutrition from your diet.
Well,
that would be ideal,
but the reality is we have the National Institute of Medicine that we're
conducting these surveys every five years.
They call them the nutrition.
In examination health surveys and hanes.
It's very notorious in the nutrition field there.
We consider n hanes surveys to be pretty accurate in determining what people are
getting from their diet and you know,
these surveys are telling us no,
people are not getting what they need from their diet.
The majority of Americans are not getting what they need in terms of
micronutrients.
Yeah,
it's really hard to do so and to do so on a daily basis requires you to really
eat clean and healthy.
Mean you can get what you need from your diet,
but boy,
you have to really mind what you're eating.
You have to really work at it and it's.
Yeah,
it's a lot of effort
and there's also the difference between the idea of you just surviving and not
getting a disease and you being at optimal health.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
That's something that our lab works on.
You know,
where we've got this sort of theory that it's hard to do aging studies in people
and particularly looking at different vitamins and minerals and what effects
they have longterm.
But that's,
that's one of the theories in our lab that we've shown some evidence of it is
that you know the,
a lot of vitamins and minerals there,
their cofactors for many different biochemical pathways in your body.
Like if you were just gonna go buy a biochemical pathways.
You'll see this like massive image come up and it's just like holy crap.
Like and vitamins and minerals are cofactors for enzymes.
Meaning they need to be there for the enzyme to work optimally in enzymes and
proteins in your body are doing everything.
I mean that's what's right and what's doing everything our is doing.
And so if you don't have,
you know,
there's certain proteins that are important to survive right now,
like your sodium potassium atpase,
you know,
you want to make sure your heart's getting the right signals you want.
I mean,
if that shuts down,
then you're dead.
You know.
So I mean some of these,
some of these functions are not.
Yeah.
So that's the biochemical pathways I'm talking about.
So these,
and that's just a snapshot,
that's just a snapshot.
So I mean all these different pathways,
they require vitamins and minerals,
essential fatty acids.
I mean these things,
it's complicated.
And so cheeseburgers don't,
don't give that everything it needs.
No,
they don't,
they don't.